hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play de gracia
phobia the beginning this is a very very
very interesting mod or a custom story
that I am very eager to try because
supposedly from what I read in the
description that you can play two
characters in it you've swap back and
forth between characters which is like a
very very interesting mechanic that I'm
intrigued to see how it's gonna work
also it's extremely exceptionally highly
rated and a very new release it's got a
nine point nine right now I mean that
may fall but for now that's pretty
incredible so let's get started mark and
Simon had known each other since college
every Friday they visited each other
sometimes the visit lasted the whole
weekend other times one of them went
home Friday night it was easy because
they lived close to each other
Mark had his own house next to an old
library next to it was a three-story
building
Simon was renting an apartment at the
second floor while he was studying Simon
wanted to be a psychologist it was still
a long way from finishing it but he
studied hard to get there it was
Saturday evening the mark was a-visiting
Simon he'd agreed in the staying until
Sunday Simon needed a book for his
studies so the two friends went to the
old library even though it was about to
close
I felt like I was being a bibliography
right there for a second but I can
forgive that a minor typos also I think
that this particular custom story has a
lot of custom music a lot of custom
stuff even though it's not a full
conversion lot but oh hello huh I
suppose I'm just walking in the old
library hello librarian mistress please
point me to the psychological books oh
well this definitely looks like a
library
my book is in another section of the
library maybe you'll find something
interesting in here meanwhile they said
that voice in my head
say you Simon Simon oh there was
something Simon said I'm mark and Blair
and Mark yes said I should look for
something interesting find advanced
mutation fine demons summoning and
exorcism fine spirits and their behavior
why I thought this was supposed to be
for psychology oh hello spirits behavior
kliklak ah hey look a chest I guess I
should go around fine
now why would I be looking at I'm gonna
get what's in this chest studium ah ah
ah no big deal just a library someone's
just walking up upstairs obviously
that is definitely custom music by the
way advanced mutation da da now why
would two psychology students be looking
for these these kids are up to no good I
swear all right now I'm curious how
we're gonna be swapping in between the
two characters I should look for
something interesting Simon is in there
I shouldn't disturb him come on he's my
best buddy why wouldn't this disturb
them I should stay in this area well
screw you I'm a rebel
I don't do oh hello
say what I need to know if Simon is safe
I freaking blocked him off Simon are you
all right you all right yes but I can't
get out please look around and see if
you can find a way to get me out of here
how about you climb over two books
oh maybe you're scared of breaking the
library okay okay all right
Simon you need to get out of here
together
and alive the bookshelves are blocking
and Simon can't get out maybe there's
another way around uh-huh I care so much
he's we're in a bromance together closet
brim haunted room
okay look flip it down
how about no yeah here um ooh ah ooh I
am Simon now haha cool cool
kind of a teleport okay but you know
okay why was Simon in here all by his
lonesome hmm private study interesting
oh this is so cool it seems like Simon's
a little bit little bit quicker a SAP
ah good I was thirsty uh-huh no 5th of
August 1835 today
Justine invited me to the library she
seemed happy and excited ah I was just
as happy I'm glad she wants to see me
again
we haven't done anything for months
even though we aren't officially
together aha I feel but there is
something between us no you're wrong
anyway
she showed me my room where I am right
now it's dark outside even though it's
summer I can't wait to see what tomorrow
will bring
I should get some sleep Adam yeah what
Wow hello
13:35 okay today just Dean came into my
room I didn't even know the library was
that big
so euphemism she told me to dress up
yeah then she pulled 11:00 next to the
bed oh-ho-ho-ho-ho mood alright when I
finished my diary
we are heading further into the library
she said I can't will stop writing in
your diary she's like throwing you all
the signals go move on buddy
Godley this guy doesn't know what's up I
[Music]
swear those of those were all you could
have all been misconstrued you see here
oh is this another book oh I can go back
to mark the good one
okay I didn't realize that this was
actually in a previous time era zone
it's locked I mean this library doesn't
seem very big I don't know how much how
long this custom story is it did say
it's only the beginning excuse me what
are you that's all
nothing sorry
curator of the library when curators
take care
I don't know I don't see anything that
was up a book fine there no okay all
right I guess there's nothing in here
come on hello I guess there's nothing
here I'll go back to the good friend
I don't I think tinder bucks count is
shared gather white sure Galloway broom
a really really broom you're not gonna
keep me trapped in here so it's stuck in
this position
so was there nothing - hiko - I'm
getting out of here
screw you Simon f fine I'll save you B
we're standing a doctor blablablabla
I've played amnesia before mr. game I
guess there's nothing for me wait did I
check that top drawer I may not have as
a top drawer that seemed to be not quite
yeah bucking are my neighbors it's a
cool concept I will admit if there's
gotta be something in let's see rare
books
ergo there must be some book that's you
know kind of rare
whoa
Oh oh yeah oh yeah
Oh knew it Oh get off so strong
whoo boom yeah screw you in your library
I need you to the door
Bewkes something tells me I'm not done
here
ah come on screw you in your face
are there any special pulley books maybe
maybe there's a book , I don't do that
to me don't do that to me
ah doesn't look like it
nope ah this is all a lie
it's all a lie let me go back to mark
anyway he was the better of the two so
maybe there was something on his end
that I was supposed to do because I was
supposed to protect Simon as I recall so
I am mark I'm alive again he defined a
lantern before one can be turned on I
mmm
so really nothing in here nothing at all
no secret button maybe no secret secret
maybe oh what's that
hang on there's a box behind there wait
wait huh wait a minute wait a minute
why is there a box back there why is
this stuff back there
hang on hi hi there me I I see them I
see him I want I see him find you
bicha bicha is that just like a red
herring i red herring
or not
whatever didn't get books I thought I
found books blast blast and damnation so
what is making me not done why am I not
done a mr. man I feel like there's
something about those stuff back there I
mean I can see a while swear they put it
there blast it all cannot believe I'm
getting stuck already dr. Simon
[Music]
you know for all of my pomp and grandeur
I do occasionally make mistakes huh no
is it no hair no oh I tell ya huh
uh-huh well come on
I want Justine to show me a good time in
the library if you know what I mean
ah why are there rooms in the library
anyway oh you know something tells me
I'm not done here yet something tells me
you need a shut up Simon cos I'm your
second douche oh I'm so mad I'm just
throwing chairs are this I'm pretty sure
I've explored everything there is to
explore over here and I don't think that
there's anything else over there ergo
the game's over and we're gonna go home
and thank you all for dobbing bye
alright we go like tomorrow one more
time before I give up this is a very
oddly placed thingamajigger no naka
digger
I just been watching futuros yeah yeah
come out okay
there's something up then maybe I have
not seen know what's that I'm a douche
oh okay unless it was like a door or
something over there I don't think
that's actually anything oh my hand does
not change at all ah
balls balls bourgeois the bookshelves
are blocking blah blah blah we need to
get out of here blah blah blah maybe
there's another way around blah blah
blah
well that sucks but I have been stuck on
pretty much the first level of every
single game I've ever played so I'm all
out of time thank you so much for
watching check the annotation for other
Let's Plays that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye